that's one socialist idea from the  democratic party um uh socialized  healthcare no that's a social social  democracy program no  it's denmark socialist and if you notice  that barack obama  the father messiah you know he's the  father messiah right  i don't know anything about that well it  beat mama michelle  uh he tried to turn america into a  socialist society what's one example of  a socialist policy that he had uh  socialized healthcare he didn't do that  he did for-profit obamacare taking care  of everybody how so by getting rid of  jobs many people emotionally took care  of people about getting rid of full-time  jobs and they had to work two part-time  jobs in order to survive so you don't  even understand the talking points the  rest stopped working and just went and  depended on and relied on the government  free obama phones  that's socialism  you're so how can you so  i want to ask a real question  i'm asking you a real question obama  phones are not socialism